meanwhile Nancy Pelosi and other animal
rights activists have rallied to the
defense of ms-13 but sadly other people
have learned the hard truth about it rob
Mickens his daughter was murdered by
ms-13 met with the president today he
joins us tonight Rob thank you for
coming out tonight oh thank you for
having me Tucker what what's your
reaction to this to the controversy
around the president's description of
ms-13 as animals he was actually being
very polite about it you know he can't
really say what's on his mind because
people like to take things out of
contact but what they did is is a savage
act and he nailed it right on her head
by calling them animals why do you think
people would defendant them because
there's always going to be somebody
who's gonna take something that the
president says and take it out of
context then they're gonna be on the
opposite side of what the president is
trying to do which is just basically
trying to help us not my family but help
us the United States the citizens of the
United States with this problem with the
ms-13 how was ruining families it sure
is
so yeah we're probably roughly the same
age I mean the ms-13 didn't exist when
you were a kid no they did it I think
they've been around for about maybe 20
years in the United States yeah what
what tell us what happened to your
daughter well my daughter Nisa Mickens
was attacked the eve of a 16th birthday
she was walking back with her best
friend Kayla back to Kayla's house and
these vicious animals approached them
and decided to kill both for them over a
dispute that happened in a high school
between Kayla and one of the members of
ms-13 I had nothing to do with your
daughter no my daughter was just at the
wrong place at the wrong time
she really was I'm sorry about that
think what what the president say to you
today he said you know we're working
hard we're going to continue to
eradicate this gang
America is giving us nothing but support
about what happened to us and to the
other families that also suffered the
same way through the crimes of the ms-13
he's sticking behind this one jab
percent and so am i I'm sorry it's it's
really a shocking and sad story Rob
thank you for coming on and telling us
that you're welcome